PAF avec Baba les chériis merci d'être
là merci je sais que vous attendiez
vraiment ce moment chez vous je vois on
est déjà en top tweet sur les réseaux
sociaux beaucoup de gens attendaient
cette émission en direct avec ce qui se
passe bien sûr en Israël beaucoup de
gens attendit des réactions de la part
des chroniqueurs des réactions de ma
part également alors hier vous avez vu
après les événements on va revenir
dessus avec Pascal dans un instant
d'ailleur qui est là parce que j'avais
pris Benaï pour Pascal mais en fait
Pascal est bien Pascal et Benaïm est
bien Benaï et c'est vrai qu'on va
revenir bien sûr sur les événements euh
tragiques qui se sont passés ce weekend
pascal vous allez nous faire un
récapitulatif de tout ce qui s'est passé
et bien entendu euh il y a beaucoup de
gens qui m'ont demandé qui m'ont dit
Cyril est-ce que tu vas réagir là-dessus
est-ce que tu vas euh donner ton avis
est-ce que tu vas nous dire ce que tu en
penses et cetera bien entendu euh je
diraiis bien sûr ce que je pense de tout
ça dans dans un instant euh et je
donnerai également mon avis sur tout
toutes les réactions on donnera notre
avis sur toutes les réaction qu'il y a
eu euh suite à ce drame et on fera 1h30
d'émission euh sur tout ce qui s'est
passé et ensuite on parlera des autres
sujets d'actualité juste Pascal merci
d'être là en tout cas ma chérie ça a été
paf ça était PAF ouais c'était ouais oui
oui oui bonne ambiance je t'ai vu tu
agité sur PAF hein t' regardé là ça y
est là non non non très bien c'est très
bien c'est très bien on va revenir sur
ce drame hein samedi matin qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé en fait pour bien comprendre
pourquoi on parle de drame ou c'est
parce qu'en fait Israël à titre de
comparaison a vécu ce weekend son 11
septembre l'attaque la plus meurtrière
que l'État hébreux n'est jamais connu
depuis sa création il y a 75 ans ça
cette date du du 6 octobre coinciite
également avec la guerre du Kipour en en
73 c'était il y a 50 ans donc c'est une
date très très symbolique l'attaque elle
a commencé à 5h30 du matin heure
française c'est-à-dire que là-bas en
Israël tout le monde dormait c'était
shabbat Chabbat c'est un peu comme
dimanche chez nous c'est-à-dire qu'on ne
travaille pas d'autant plus que c c'est
c'est un plus que que dimanche chez nous
parisque voilà il y en a beaucoup qui
font qui font le Chabbat donc ils font
ils allument pas la lumière ils ont pas
le téléphone donc voilà ils ont pas la
télé ils ont pas voilà donc ils ont pas
l'électricité donc forcément c'est c'est
plus voilà que que le dimanche chez nous
voilà le dimanche moi je voilà je vous
allez faire vos courses tranquilles
aussi hein voilà non exactement j'allais
le dire effectivement donc certains
étaient pas informés parce qu' pas de
téléphone pas de pas de pas de
télévision mais c'est donc le Hamas qui
est reconnu comme étant en Europe et par
les États-Unis une organisation
terroriste islamiste qui il a il y a
combien de pays euh qui ne reconnaissent
pas le Hamas comme une organisation
terroriste je crois qu'il y en a je
crois qu'il y en a que trois ou quatre
hein c'est ça ou là dans le dans les
dans les réactions qui sont qui ont
suivi ces événements absolument
tragiques et qui en effet vont
bouleverser à mon avis le monde pour un
bon moment il n'y a que trois pays
d'Afrique qui euh qui n'ont pas condamné
immédiatement et qui ne se sont pas
rangés du côté de j'ai envie de dire de
l'humanité en fait de l'humanité
consiste à condamner ce qui s'est passé
la Tunisie l'Algérie et l'Iran qui ont
reconnu au droit au territoire
palestinien de se défendre eux n'ont pas
condamné effectivement cette cette
attaque en fait les c'était des attaques
coordonnées les combattants du Hamas
sont arrivés à bord de véhicules à bord
de bateaux à bord de parapentees
motorisé en même temps il y a des
milliers de roquettes qui ont été tirées
sur Israël le Hamas parle de 5000
roquettes qui ont été tiré en même temps
ils ont utilisé des explosifs des
buldoers aussi pour franchir cette cette
barrière alors on va revenir sur tout ce
qui s'est passé parce que là on va un
petit peu vite c'est donc samedi un
matin vers 5h30 du matin donc plein
Chabbat comme vous l'avez dit des
milliers de roquettes donc sont sont
lancées sur le pays et leurs combattants
ont utilisé donc des explosifs et des
bulleszir pour franchir la barrière qui
sépare on va dire la bande de Gaza du
territoire
israélien on va regarder
euh des une compile de tir de missile
c'était 5h30 du matin et voilà ce qui se
passait
[Musique]
donc ça 5h30 du matin donc
Pascal derrière
euh il se passe que il y a une rêve
partie qui est organisé avec des
militants je crois pour la paix en plus
hein très près de de la frontière et et
là ce sont des des combattants qui sont
arrivés notamment avec ses ses
parapantes motorisé et qui qui ont tir à
vue il y a plus de 250 morts des jeunes
donc effectivement ça c'est l'un des
symboles les plus forts de ce qui s'est
passé en terme de de de de victime cette
trève partie qui a fait plus de de 250
victimes c'est vrai que ces combattants
sont pris au civil parce qu'ils sont
rentrés dans les maisons ils ont pris
des otages femmes enfants des personnes
âgées mais aussi des personnes en
situation de de handicap a 150
prisonniers qui sont F 85 ans par
exemple exement on on va voir cette
image tout à l'heure avec cette femme de
85 ans qui a été
kidnappé
derrière 150 otages donc son son au
mains du Hamas sajacques 250 150 pardon
aujourd'hui il là oui une centaine
encore sont encore aux mains de du Hamas
et ça va être effectivement un énorme
problème pour Benyamin netaniaahou parce
qu'on sait l'importance dans ces
conflitsl de l'importance de la vie
évidemment des otages des otages et ça
complique évidemment toutes les prises
de positions politiques ensuite pour le
gouvernement de d'État ce que je
voudrais expliquer moi il est bientôt
19h c'est toutes ces réactions euh qu'on
suivit puisqu'on va voir toutes les
images dans un instant euh c'est ça
c'est notamment tous ces civils euh qui
n'avaient rien à voir là-dedans euh qui
se sont retrouvés ou kidnappés ou tué
euh j'ai vu des des des gens voilà qui
étaient donc a une rêve partie en plus
qui une rêve partie pour la paix qui se
sont retrouvés à courir à fuir certains
ont pu fuir pour les les les les les les
plus heureux et puis bien sûr d'autres
ont péri euh sous les balles et c'est
vrai que euh parce qu'il y a eu plein de
réactions il y a eu plein de réactions
on va reparler de toutes les réactions
dans dans un instant mais je crois que
c'est c'est surtout ça euh qui a fait
que les réactions étaient unanimes
Pascal ou des réactions unanimes et puis
beaucoup de vidéos qui ont aussi tourné
sur sur les réseaux sociaux et qui ont
rapporté l'horreur et parfois des vidéos
non authentifiées mais vous en parlz euh
euh souvent parce que ça fait énormément
réagir mais le bilan des victimes est
quand même de au moins 700 morts côté
israélien plus de 2000 blessés euh on a
deux Français de français de nos
compatriotes également qui sont qui sont
décédés et côté palestinien parce qu'
évidemment l'armée israélienne a a
répondu on en est à près de 600 morts
aussi côté palestinien puisque Israël a
officiellement déclaré la guerre
dimanche officiellement au au Hamas
évidemment tsal puisque c'est le nom de
de l'armée israélienne est intervenue
dès le samedi mais mais a déclaré la
guerre donc dimanche il y a des dizaines
de milliers de soldats qui ont été
appelés euh au sud au sud au sud
d'Israël puisque c'est par là fait que
les combattants sont du Hamas sont
entrés ils ont été déployés
effectivement sur cette partie sud
d'Israël non seulement pour chasser les
terroristes parce que parce qu'il y
avait encore des terroristes rien ne
garantissait que tous les terroristes
avaient été maîtrisés donc ils sont
partis combattre ils ont récupéré les
localités c'est ce qu'ils ont dit il y a
quelques heures l'armée israélienne et
localité qui avait été attaqué sur le
sur le sud sur le sud d'Israël et ils
ont bombardé également Gaza la nuit
dernière pour qu'on se rende bien compte
Gill j'aimerais que tu nous dises ce qui
s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé le samedi à 5h30 si
on était en France ce serait quoi ben ce
serait effectivement des milliers de
morts c'est une attaque surprise alors
que les gens
étaient au saut du lit pour des
militaires qu'on a trouvé en caleçon qui
ont été réveillés et pour ces gens dont
vous parlez à la rêveptie c'est une
rêveptie le Nova festival qui est très
amicale une fête annuelle et là ils ont
vu déferler vers eux des gens en
uniforme israéliens pour la plus part
donc ils ont pensé que c'était l'armée
d'Israël qui venait et en fait les les
terroristes du Hamas par dizaine ou par
centaines avait des uniformes israéliens
pour les surprendre et là dans
l'épouvante le plus épouvantable dans ce
drame peut-être c'est ça c'est ces 260
personnes parce qu'elles ont été fusillé
comme ça ces jeunes ont été fusillés
tués assassinés alors qu'ils
participaient à un festival qui n'avait
je vrais dire moi ces jeunes ils font
pas de politique ces jeunes dans une
rêve partie et et je vais vous dire il
est même peu probable qu'il soit qui qu'
les a voté pour tel ou tel gouvernement
en Israël c'était des jeunes qui
voulaiit juste faire la fête pour la
plupart en plus c'était
des des défenseurs de la paix donc ça
voilà parce que tout le monde nous a dit
pourquoi ce tel retondissement c'est
aussi pour ça pour ces images qu'on va
voir là
[Musique]
regardez
si incroyable vraiment je vous dis vu
ces images tourné sur les réseaux tout
le weekend forcément vous avez les avez
vu également on va revenir sur tout ce
qui s'est passé dans un instant avec
toutes les questions et je vous le dis
on posera également les questions qui
fâchent parce que voilà on est une
émission un petit peu spéciale on va
poser aussi des questions qui Fa je vous
donnerai mon sentiment aussi sur tout ce
que j'ai pu voir sur les réseaux sociaux
même concernant bien entendu hier et je
vous donnerai mon sentiment aussi sur
tout ce que je vois
euh c'est ces gens qui qui s'invectivent
et le retentissement en France que je
sens déjà arriver et vraiment j'aV
j'avis envie de vous dire plein de
choses dans un instant parce que j'ai
parlé avec sor il a un instant ma ma
coiffeuse
elle m'a dit moi je comprends rien de ce
qui se passe j'habite dans le 12e je
suis coiffeuse en France et j'ai
l'impression que ça me retombe
dessus c'est pas con ce qu'elle m'a dit
et on va par par tout ça dans un instant
et on va parler également des gens il y
a des gens qui mettent le drapeau
israélien sur les réseaux qui se font
menacer de mort il y a des mecs qui
mettent le drapeau palestinien qui se
font menacer de mort et j'ai vu plein de
gens hier DRAE drapeau israélien les
mecs mettent le drapeau israélien ils
sont menacés de mort aujourd'hui on
c'est pas c'est pas la solution je vous
dis c'est pas la solution et je va vous
dire ce que je pense de tout ce que je
vois sur les réseaux et toute cette
haine qu'on voit sur les réseaux moi
aujourd'hui vous le savez j'ai toujours
dit je voilà je suis de confession juive
je parle toujours des faites juif je
parle toujours mais pour moi voilà
forcément j'ai été très touché par ce
qui s'est passé hier et comme vous tous
comme tout le monde
ici